digamos que estás muy feliz paseando en
la calle y llega alguien y te dice
rápido 57 más que es igual a 73 cuanto
vale este espacio de aquí bueno pues hay
un par de formas para resolver esta
pregunta y este espacio en blanco es
básicamente lo que le tienes que sumar a
57 para obtener 73 o visto de otra forma
este espacio en blanco es 73 menos 57
entonces pues podemos empezar con 57 y
bueno de hecho lo que vamos a hacer es
tal cual lo que yo hago en mi cabeza
cuando me preguntan algo de este estilo
yo empiezo con 57 y le voy sumando
números de tal forma que la suma sea un
número muy redondo y me acerque cada vez
más a 73
así es que empezando en 57 podemos ver
que es muy fácil llegar a 60 sin nada
más sumamos 3 por aquí ok entonces yo
sumaría un 3
para que me quede un número muy redondo
que es 60 cree 50 y 73 es 60 y ahora de
60 a 73 pues nada más le tenemos que
sumar 13 cierto y ese fue un cálculo
super sencillo que podemos hacer en la
cabeza y bueno si lo quisiéramos hacer
todavía más sencillo y paso por paso
pudimos haber dicho que hay de 60 vamos
a llegar a 70 sumando 10 y después a 73
sumando otros 30 pues este cálculo es
tan sencillo que podemos directamente
sumar 13 así es que todo esto es 73
ahora a final de cuentas cuánto le
sumamos a 57 para llegar a 73 pues le
sumamos
es más 13 y 313 es 16
así es que 16 57 es igual a 73 y listo
ahora también hay otras formas para
encontrar este espacio de aquí por
ejemplo pues aquí este espacio en blanco
este espacio vacío es la resta de 73
menos 57 y lo podemos escribir por aquí
73 menos 57 es igual al espacio vacío y
bueno si calculamos esta resta nos va a
quedar exactamente el mismo resultado 16
y hay distintas formas de realizar esta
resta pero si quisiera yo resolver esta
pregunta en mi cabeza yo haría esto de
aquí y vamos con más
estas preguntas ahora digamos que sigues
paseando en la calle y llega otra
persona y te dice rápido rápido si
tienes 94 - algún número al cual le
vamos a llamar el espacio vacío igual a
57 cuánto vale
este número de aquí entonces tenemos la
misma situación lo que hoy tenemos 94 y
nos estamos preguntando cuánto le
tenemos que restar a 94 para llegar a 57
y bueno para resolver rápidamente este
problema podemos usar la misma técnica
del ejercicio pasado empezamos desde 94
y le vamos restando números que hagan
que el resultado sea un número redondo y
fácil de recordar y así les seguimos
restando números hasta que llegamos a 57
entonces empezamos por 94 y de hecho es
así es la técnica que yo usaría si
tuviera que resolver este problema en mi
cabeza
entonces pues empezamos en 94 y le vamos
a restar 4 para llegar a 90 un número
muy bonito y veamos después le podemos
restar 20 para llegar a 60 ok no nos
queremos pasar de 60 ok porque de 60
nada más tenemos que restar 3 y ya
llegamos a 57 no queremos llegar a
ningún número más abajo de 57 así es que
restamos 20 y 90 menos 20 o no espera es
que no es menos 20 tienen que ser menos
30 para llegar a 60 entonces le restamos
30 y ahora si 90 menos 30
eso
si son 60
y para llegar de 60 a 57 lo único que
necesitamos es restar 360 menos 3
todo esto si es 57 entonces en total
cuanto le reste a 94 pues le reste menos
4 menos 30 y menos 3 y de todo esto son
menos 37 que le reste 37 y bueno esta no
es la única forma de encontrar este
número también pudimos haber dicho acá y
94 - el espacio vacío es igual a 57 eso
significa que 57 más el espacio vacío
tiene que ser igual a 94 y lo vamos a
escribir por aquí 57 más el espacio
vacío es igual a 94 también pudimos
haber tratado de resolver este problema
de esta forma y aquí otra vez hacemos lo
mismo que en el ejercicio pasado
ok empezamos con 57 y decimos oye si le
sumamos 3
llegamos a 60 y ya que tenemos 60
entonces pues le podemos sumar otros 30
y llegamos a 90 y a partir de 90 le
sumamos otros 4 y llegamos a 94 y
entonces en total habremos un 93 más 30
más 4 que son 37 así es que el espacio
también fue 37 ahora claramente hay
otras formas de resolver esto sobre todo
si tienes lápiz y papel a la mano puedes
hacerlo más fácil con otras formas pero
pues esta es la forma en la que yo lo
resolvería si estuviera paseando en la
calle y alguien llega y me pregunta oye
cuánto vale está cantidad de aquí porque
es muy fácil hacer estos cálculos en la
cabeza pero bueno hagamos otro de estos
ejercicios digamos que ahora llega a
alguien y te dice tengo 36 igual
un espacio vacío -41 cuánto tiene que
valer este espacio vacío de aquí y bueno
en estos casos a mí lo que más fácil se
me hace es decir esto es lo mismo que si
tomamos 36 y le sumamos 41 y el
resultado de esa suma tiene que ser
igual a este espacio vacío ok
estos dos no se están diciendo lo mismo
y si no te parece tan claro que nos
estén diciendo lo mismo podemos dibujar
una recta numérica
que vamos a poner una recta numérica por
acá y está nuestra recta numérica y lo
que esta ecuación nos está diciendo es
que empezamos en un número nuestro
espacio vacío vamos a ponerlo por acá
con un signo de interrogación y lo que
nos dice este enunciado es que si
empezamos en este número que no
conocemos y le restamos 41 vamos a
restarle 41
- 41 entonces llegamos a 36
ahora si empezamos en 36 y después le
sumamos 41
41 le sumamos 41 como podemos ver aquí
llegamos justo a este número no cree el
espacio vacío entonces pues cuánto vale
este número cuánto vale el espacio vacío
a ver vamos a empezar por aquí sumando
las unidades tenemos seis unidades más
una unidad
esas son siete unidades y luego pues
tenemos tres decenas más cuatro decenas
o sea siete decenas así es que es 77 ok
este número es 77 y listo ya terminamos